sexy dancing plastic surgery and a story
that makes me happy I didn't pursue a
career as an adult webcam model
Netflix's latest Korean drama that
doesn't have the word squid in it is a
brutal portrayal of Love revenge and the
dangers of parasocial relationships in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive
into mask girl it's ending in some of
the details you missed along the way but
before we begin to make sure to donate
all your heart pangs by clicking the
like And subscribe button to appease my
last remaining serotonin meet Mass girl
AKA Kim Momi a girl who grew up with
dreams of becoming a famous star loved
by all there's just one problem she's
terribly ugly
bullied by her classmates and even her
mom Mass girl Retreats into his
seemingly mundane Life falling for her
handsome boss who photoshops his abs Mr
Park but Mass girl has a double life
when she comes home from work she dons
the mass to become the number one viewed
performer on Pang TV V an online
platform where men can interact with
women and live out their parasocial
fantasies there she becomes that star
she always dreamed she would be there
she is desired for her looks something
she never gets in the real world but
Mass girl's life is soon to come
crashing down with the introduction of
juo Nam like masker onam grew up bullied
for his looks and constantly berated by
his mother he retreated more and more
into himself becoming a loner who sought
companionship online there he met Mass
girl becoming her number one fan and
little do both of them know but they
work together in the same office growing
up Onan was so afraid of girls he'd
never look them in the eye so instead he
focused on their hands and one day at
work notices something about Momi she
has identical moles on each hand and
green colored nail polish the same that
mass girl has this only fuels his
obsession as he has visions of
professing his love to her and also
getting a bj but both their lives are
about to change when Mass girl ends up
defending herself on a date from a horny
fan who slips off a waterbed and bashes
his head against the counter now Mass
girl thinks this guy is dead and onam
who had been stalking her offers to help
dispose of the body but what Mass girl
doesn't know is that he isn't dead and
when he regains Consciousness onam
viciously finishes the job this whole
event is too much for Mass girl to deal
with and she decides to skip town which
onam does not want he begs her not to
leave but when she accuses him of being
like all the other weird stalker dudes
he forces himself upon her this is where
Mass girl commits her first real murder
and it's revealed that she's had her
face surgically altered to start a new
life on her own a new life where she can
be what she's always wanted pretty in
the real world this is where the story
really begins as we begin the final
episode we fast forward 14 years is to
find mass girl in prison two years after
the murder of onam she was captured and
found guilty she finally got to be that
big star she always dreamed of uh
but in those two years before her
capture Mass girl gave birth to a
daughter mimo not to be confused with Mo
me which is mass girl when onam forced
himself upon her he knocked her up and
mask girl abandons mimo and sends her to
live with her abusive grandmother under
normal circumstances this would be the
end of the story and life would go on
but it's the determination of one woman
that leads us to the stories chilling
climax meet Kim kyongya the mother of
onam she grew up a single mom working
countless undesirable jobs to provide
for her boy when she finds out her son
was murdered by mass girl she vows to
track her down and kill her and boy is
she determined she takes computer
classes in an effort to gain Clues as to
mass girls wherever the friends seedy
Men Who Run Mass girl fan sites and
travels across the country in her search
she eventually finds Mass girl but is
outsmarted by her and her friend Chennai
mask girl believing that kilya is dead
dumps her body and car in a lake but
kyungya survives she continues her plans
for Revenge but they're thwarted when
Mass girl is arrested but soon there's
an even more nefarious way she finds
that she can get back at her upon
learning Mass girl has a daughter
kyungya devises an elaborate plan to
befriend memo while simultaneously
destroying her life she wants Mass girl
to watch as she ruins her daughter's
life just like mask girl ruined her sons
this involves killing you getting
plastic surgery herself and becoming
this grandmother figure to memo to gain
her trust memo even ends up running away
with her to her home up in the mountains
when Kenya comes to prison and reveals
that she's still alive to her she knows
that her daughter's life is in danger so
she finds a way to escape by offering to
give up her kidney to the daughter of an
influential inmate who holds sway over
the warden and during the day of the
surgery mask girl escapes from the
hospital window and commandeers a
vehicle to save her daughter at the same
time hyungya has drugged memo and plans
to record her death and send it to mass
girl as a final Act of Revenge luckily
Mass girl's mother and mimo's friend Yi
Chun have pieced together that memo has
run off with kyunya and that this old
lady could pose a serious threat to
mimo's safety so what happens is a
convergence of several characters all
descending upon kyung's home in an epic
finale when memo awakens from being
drugged she can't believe what's
happening the one person she's trusted
in her life has turned against her and
she doesn't understand that kyongya is
doing this as an act of Revenge there's
even a fun moment where a police officer
arrives and takes a look around the
house but kyungya has built this hidden
underground cell Mass girl's mom is the
first to arrive resulting in the two
grannies going at it but unfortunately
for her she's killed by a pair of
scissors her last words are I'm sorry no
doubt an apology for the way she treated
her daughter her entire life it's mascal
herself who saves mimo and Yi Chun and
she fights kyongya to the death emerging
Victorious from The Cellar but kyung
basically has a hundred lives she's like
a Terminator returning for one final
Salvo as the police surround the house
hyungya aims her shotgun at memo but
Mass girl steps in the way sacrificing
herself so that her daughter can live
jungya is shot by the police and killed
as well this is how you know you're
dealing with a Korean show and not an
American one because even as kyungya
aims her gun the police are still trying
to talk her down instead of immediately
blasting her to Kingdom Come the ending
is one of tragedy with mass girl her
mother and kyongya along with countless
others along the way dead but there is
some silver lining memo goes to live
with her friend Yi Chun and her family
and she says that the hate she felt in
her heart toward other people has been
lifted the nightmares she had of her
mother have also disappeared while going
through her mother's things she uncovers
some maracas and a camcorder relics from
the 1980s when her mother still had
those dreams of becoming famous her
mother's dream was to become a person
everyone loved very much and the tragedy
is that she never got that but mimo
knows her mother's Final Act was one of
Selfless Love even though the world was
cruel to her she still found a way for
love to persevere Mass girl shows us The
Power of Love by depicting the two
extremes people can go while fueled by
it in an act of love for her son kyungya
seeks revenge while in an act of love
for her daughter Mass girl sacrifices
herself but mask girl is also the story
of generational trauma we have parents
passing on their abuse to their children
and them taking it out on others in one
of mass girl's prison letters it even
asks is violence genetic while violence
may not necessarily be genetic Mass
girls shows us that it can definitely be
learned and that hate which fuels
violence can be healed but what did you
think of mass girls tragic ending I want
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below thanks for watching please be sure
to like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember
foreign